نعود مره اخرى الى ملف السودان ينضم الينا
من جنوب الخرطوم مراسل الجزيره طاهر
المرضي الطاهر الوضع الميداني في دارفور
كيف هو الان
الوضع الميداني في دارفور ماساه ماساه في
بكل ما تحمل هذه الكلمه من معنى وخاصه في
التقرير الذي اصدرته نقابه الاطباء تقول
ان الوضع كارثي وان كل الخدمات الاساسيه
تعطلت تماما سواء كانت الصحه او المياه او
الكهرباء او حتى الاتصالات لا يمكن
الاتصال بما يدور الان ومعرفه ما يدور في
مدينه الجنينه حتى المواطنون الذين يودون
مغادره الجنينه لا يستطيعون
سيقابلهم البعض اما بالقتل او بالنهب او
غير ذلك بالنسبه
للامهات او بالنسبه للجرحى بالنسبه للجرحى
يقول وتقول هذا التقرير الذي صدر من نقابه
الاطباء
لا يجدون حتى العنايه يموت بعضهم وكان
يمكن تفادي هذه الامور اذا كان هنالك وضع
صحي او اي نوع من الرعايه الصحيه الامهات
يواجهون مخاطر اولاد الغير امنه اذا هذه
العبارات وهذه النقاط التي وردت في تقرير
النقابه الاطباء تكشف بجلاء ان الوضع
الكارثي في تلك المدينه خاصه وان كل
المنظمات الانسانيه غادرت هذه المدينه
بسبب الاوضاع المتدهوره وكان في تصريح
سابق لحاكم اقليم دارفور من اركن الناوي
طالب الحكومه التشاديه بفتح حدودها
لاستقبال الجرحى بسبب تعطل وانهيار النظام
الصحي في هذه المدينه اذا المدينه تعيش
حاله من الماساه وحاله من القلق والتدهور
وعدم الامن جعل يعني الحياه فيها تكون
صعبه وليس هنالك اي حديث عن انقاذ هذا
الوضع او اي نوع من التحرك او معرفه حتى
طبيعه هذا الصراع في داخل هذه المدينه حتى
الان المعلومات شحيحه الاتصال بهذه
المدينه يبدو صعبا للغايه لا يمكن ان تتصل
بمسؤول او اي نوع من الجهات التي يمكن ان
تكشف عن حقيقه هذا الوضع هذا هو الوضع في
ولايه غرب دارفور وكذلك في ولايه وسط
دارفور يعني هنالك ماسي حقيقيه بسبب الحرب
الدائره هناك شكرا لك يا طاهر المرضي
الجزيره المتحدثا من جنوب الخرطوم